All right. Yes, guys, welcome back to
another video. I'm going to be showing
you how I made eight R in a matter of
two days. I'm going to show you guys
step-by-step what I'm looking for, what
time periods I'm looking for these
setups, and what exactly needs to be
seen in order to take these setups. What
sessions are we actually trading now?
The New York open, which happens at 9:30
a.m. New York local time. So, if you're
in the UK like myself, that'll be 2:30
p.m. And then you'll be trading until
the end of the PM macro. So, I trade
till the end of the PM session. So, that
would be till 2:15 p.m. New York local
time, which for me in the UK is 7:15
p.m. I trade until 9:30 a.m. to 2:15.
But sometimes if we're not finding a
trade throughout the day, and it is
quite slow, then I'll just set some
alerts, and I won't bother looking at
the charts until I see something of
interest. Otherwise, there's no point
just sitting at your desk. You may as
well get on with some other stuff like
edit some videos, or if you got to go
and do some other business apart from
trading, then that's the perfect
opportunity to be doing that. Macro
entries are obviously an added
confluence. What you do see happen
sometimes is that in between the macros,
price will just be consolidating, or
it'll be making its move to a certain
point of liquidity. Now, this is exactly
why we used to trade the macros, is
because they're the highest probability,
you know, time zones for where these
trades occur, and where they play out
really, really nicely. But there are
lots of times where outside a macro, a
trade will algorithmically play out
perfectly. So, just trading the full
session completely eliminates the fact
that you missed those trades. And if a
trade
presents itself, then it's valid to
take. So, you basically will never miss
a setup that's within your set of rules,
if that makes sense. Now, what sweeps do
I look for? I look for 15-minute highs
and lows to get swept. But for me
personally, I don't need to see a
15-minute swing high or swing low get
swept, but I'll definitely prefer a
swing point. However, if it's clear
where price is drawing to, and it sweeps
like an internal 15-minute low, so it's
not quite a swing low, but if internal
point, then I'll also count that, too.
There's many times I've taken trades and
it's delivered absolutely perfect off a
15-minute internal low, say instead of a
premium. And also session liquidity, so
that's your highest probability
liquidity, so we're talking London
highs, Asia highs, New York lows, lunch
highs, lunch lows, etc. So, that's your
session liquidity. And also, I look for
continuations out of gaps. So, if you're
looking at the 5 and 50-minute time
frame, if price is trading out of those
points, say a bearish gap or a bullish
gap, then you can take a a continuation
to the upside. So, one of the recent
trades I took from last week was price
trading out of a 5-minute bullish gap.
And then I took a, you know, we had a
shift in market structure, fair value
gap, and just before we took all-time
highs, I took longs cuz we didn't
technically take that point of buy side
off a bullish order block, and it
delivered absolutely perfectly for a 2R.
Top ticked, literally top ticked the
market, and it dropped to like 400
points. So, holy top tick. Trade
management. How are we managing the
trades now? I still use the same system
as usual, but I also do use system of
trailing based off the R multiple. So,
if you're going for a 3R trade, then
every single R that you make, you trail
to those points. So, if it hits a 1R,
you trail aggressively, hits a 2R, you
go break even, and if it hits a 3R, then
obviously you let the trade play out for
a 3R. I don't like to be so systematic
anymore in terms of the way I trail. I
look at the scenario, that's why it says
two different scenarios. I'm looking at
the first scenario where if we're If I'm
looking at price and I think something's
going to happen and it's like a bad
scenario, so there's a high probable
chance that price's going to run to my
stop loss after we take the swing high,
then I will trail aggressively, yeah?
So, I wouldn't obviously do it based off
emotion, I would go based off what I'm
seeing. And if that's what I think is
going to happen, then I'm going to
trail. There's no point leaving an open
risk if you think something's going to
happen and then it happens and you've
just lost more money than you really
should have. Uh but then also, when
you're going for positions, you don't
want to trail too aggressive. Going
based off our multiple is the correct
decision, because then you're giving
price enough chance and breathing room
to actually play out, work off
the imbalances and the order blocks and
all these PD arrays that play in favor
for the trade to actually work out.
If they get disrespected, then
obviously, hopefully there'll be points
below it or above it, depending if
you're long or short, for price to work
off.
Uh, if there isn't, then you'd
potentially just be leaving a completely
open risk, or you would have trailed
aggressively by then for when you've hit
that 1R. So, those are the two different
scenarios. You either use the same
system where you trail at the first
short-term high because you believe
something's going to happen, or you
believe that's the most appropriate way
of managing this position, or you use
the point of trailing based off our
multiple, and if you feel like that's
the correct decision for the trade, then
go for it. Now, you're probably
wondering, well, how do I know? Looking
at what you're seeing, so if you
understand price action, then you'll
know. But, it's kind of hard to teach it
to you unless you've been in the Discord
watching me trade every day, or you've
been you've stuck around long enough to
know the way that I trade and what I'm
basically seeing and looking for. Yeah.
Okay, so this is on Thursday, the 21st
of May, and this is when we were coming
into the New York AM session. So, we're
actually inside of the first day of
macro, too. And what we can see here is
we have a clear sweep of buy-side
liquidity. Is this a 15-minute swing
high? There we have it, no doubt about
it. This is a sweep of buy-side
liquidity, and we're also trading out of
a 15-minute bearish gap. So, two lovely
confluences to support looking for
shorts. All right, so now what can we
see here? We've got a sweep of buy-side,
and we've also swapped the most recent
short-term high. So, if we got a shift
in our market structure now, this would
be an absolutely beautiful unicorn model
to look for shorts. Okay, so we can see
here we have a clear shift in market
structure on NQ, clear shift in market
structure on the S&P 500. Now, what are
we looking for? We're looking for a
bullish order block to get inverse.
Where can we see it? On ES right here.
This bullish order block gets inverse
and what's it paired with? It's paired
with a fair value gap on ES. We have a
clear shift on NQ and we have that
bearish gap that's been presented and
you can see that NQ has actually filled
this bearish gap. So, this would have
been your entry. Your stop placement
would be at the recent swing high.
Sometimes now with my stop placements
too, I'm actually putting it two
previous swing highs if the RR is good
enough. So, let's say you know you've
got it at this recent swing high and
your two R is just here for the benefit
of having more room and not getting
faked out where price takes out the
recent swing high and goes lower. I run
my stop loss just a bit higher to be
safer and have it in a better position
and then I'll look for a two R at the
opposing draw on liquidity which is
clear price is going to go and draw to
hit anyway because in the first AM
session too, especially in that first AM
macro, when price has offered a super
buy side, clear shift of market
structure, it's offered the model
perfectly.
Nine times out of 10 it's going to go to
that draw if the model does play out.
So, let's see how this runs. In this
scenario here, we can see we have this
swing low on NQ that's 50% of the range
between our entry point and TP. So, once
price takes this point, I would be going
break even. All right, there we go. So,
100% risk free now. So, now I'll be
looking for price to take out our take
profit. All right, there we go. So,
price trades out of the 1-minute bearish
gap to the left.
And there we go, TP smashed. Absolutely
perfect. Textbook ICT silver bullet
model. Okay, so after price hit TP on
NQ, we can see that price has rallied up
to the upside and if we go on the
15-minute time frame, we can see that
we're trading out of that 15-minute
bearish gap again and ES has taken out a
15-minute swing high. So, this is a
clear sweep of buy side liquidity and
we're trading out of a bearish gap. So,
two confluences again to be looking for
shorts. We've clearly taken out
this recent short-term high. So, we have
a shift in market structure on the S&P
500 through this swing low, and we have
a shift in market structure on NQ
through this swing low. Now, where is
our inverse order block on ES? We have
this one right here to the left.
That is paired with the fair value gap.
This model right here is valid for
shorts. All right, there we go. So,
right there we'd be in for shorts, and
I'd run my stop loss just at this recent
swing low, and have my TP for a 2R.
Okay, so once price takes out this first
swing low, I definitely would not want
to see price return back to this fair
value gap. I'd want to see an
acceleration lower. There isn't really
much for price to work out of. If it
does return, we just have the bearish
fair value gap, which has already been
filled based off our entry. So, I'm
going to trail my stop loss just above
the swing high.
Bang, and there we go.
2R smashed. That candle aggression was
crazy. I remember this being out of the
time. Absolutely spot-on entry, spot-on
execution, and that is exactly what we
do every single week. If you go back on
the channel, you'll be able to see me
take this trade live. Absolutely banger.
So, 15-minute time frame, we've got a
clear sweep of buy-side liquidity. It's
actually London highs. So, that is our
session sweep. And then we can see that
we've clearly swept out the most recent
swing high. And then, where is our shift
in market structure? Here's our shift on
NQ. This is our shift on ES. So, here's
how I was able to get an absolutely
spot-on entry at 29618.
ES at the time didn't actually shift
market structure. It didn't close just
below the displacement just yet. So,
this is something new that I've also
implemented. If the model was there, and
ES hasn't quite shifted, and there's a
model to take, I will take the trade,
but if ES then fails to shift on the
next candle, I will close out that
position. But, if ES then also does
shift in the next candle, then I'll stay
in, and I have a better entry. And if ES
fills the shift, it's more than likely
price is still at break even anyway. So,
it's completely fine. So, that's my way
of not letting trades run without me
just because
ES has not shifted yet. Okay, cool. So,
I've got my stop placement and TP at the
ready. Now, how am I going to trail this
position?
I'm going to go based off
the New York open. That's where I'm
going to go break even 100%. That's a
sweep of liquidity of sell side that
I'll definitely be looking at, and I
would take a position if price was to
say have swept this point, and I was
looking for longs. So, 100% New York
open low. If it takes that point, I'm
going break even. All right, so we can
see as of now, price trades back up to
take out this short-term high, and
trades into this bearish gap. So, we'll
see if price respects these points and
moves lower.
There we go. So, that is the volatility
we were looking for to the downside.
NQ takes out one, two swing lows. So,
I'm trailing my stop loss just above
this short-term high.
And there we go. So, NQ takes out this
break even point, which is the New York
open low. And I really wanted to just
see price run through this area, and not
return because there's a very high
chance that price would tap into a high
time frame imbalance to the left, which
is likely a 5 or 15, and react out of
this New York open low. So, I'm
completely break even here. Okay, so
we're getting very close to TP here.
Now, what I didn't do was trail my stop
loss to this recent high. I had my eyes
on this bearish fair value gap up here.
It was a you know, a POI, a point of
interest for me that price may
potentially tap into, and then come down
lower. And to be honest, I'd rather just
get taken out at break even than get
taken out at this point. I mean, you're
that close to TP, I'm going to be pissed
off anyway.
Well, not really pissed off, but I'd
rather give price the chance to work out
of the imbalances and draw lower than
get taken out early and miss out on
profits. So, you can see that price
perfectly to the tick taps this bearish
fair value gap and works lower.
And you'll see
we smashed TP just like that. And that
is why I did not trail to this high. I
trailed to the high of this fair value
gap. So, slightly in a profit. So, you
know, I wouldn't have got completely out
break even, but basically break even.
And that's what I done for that position
right there. All right, so we're in the
PM session now. I didn't take any more
trades throughout the day. I wanted to
wait for the PM just because I didn't
like the way price was kind of chopping
around in this range here. So, I waited
for price to sweep up on a buy side
which we can see here. Price came up and
swept this point.
And now I have a more confident idea of
understanding of where price is likely
going to draw to coming into the PM.
What I know from the PM macro is that
when it offers a model coming into the
session of the macro is absolutely
beautiful. The delivery is
out of this world. We've got a shift
lower in market structure on NQ. We've
got a shift lower on ES. Where's our
bullish order block? We can see it's
right here on the S&P 500. It's paired
with that fair value gap. We've got a
fair value gap on NQ. We'll look for an
entry off that point. Bang, there we go.
So, we're short on NQ. Running my stop
loss at the short-term high and then my
TP for a one to two. I'm going to see
how price reacts. If it puts in a swing
high when we trade out of this gap, then
once it takes the swing low, I'll trail
to the recent swing high. Then once we
take out this swing low right here, I'd
100% be break even.
Cool. So, we can see here NQ has taken
out the first swing low. And what's it
put in?
A swing high. So, we're going to trail
stops to this recent short-term high.
Now,
there we go. Didn't even have to worry
about break even. I mean, when we trail
to that point, you practically are break
even, but perfectly ticked our TP to the
point and
3 minutes we hit TP on that for a 2R.
So, those were the four executions I
took on the 21st and 22nd of May that
was able to secure me 8R in profit and I
took all of these live on the Discord.
If you do want to see me take these
executions, all the details will be down
below. You can either go directly to the
website to purchase either just a
monthly if you want to see what it's
like for a month or lifetime. There's
also a purchase for one-to-one
mentorship, which will give you free
access to the live streams anyway. And
it's all lifetime as well. There's no
additional fees after that. And if you
do want to just get inside for free and
you know, you're not looking to join,
but you just want to get inside of the
community, there's a free Discord down
below as well where you're able to
contact me, too.
So, I hope you guys have enjoyed this
video. If you did, make sure to drop a
like, subscribe, and use code Ash10 as
well at Alpha Futures if you are
grabbing some Eva. Send me a screenshot.
My Instagram is down below, too, or on
Discord if you're using the code and
you'll be entered into a giveaway. I do
a giveaway once every like 3 weeks or 2
weeks. So, pretty much monthly giveaways
out for you guys to win. So, I hope you
guys have enjoyed and I'll catch you in
the next one. Peace.